we're still waiting for a briefing from
President Trump in the White House
coronavirus task force initially the
media had been complaining about a lack
of those very briefings but now they
almost there almost a daily presence in
our lives but momentum is building to
stop airing these briefings the New York
Times with this headline quote Trump's
briefings are a ratings hit should
networks cover them live and some in the
media say we shouldn't show them at all
if it were up to me and it's not I would
stop putting those briefings on live TV
not out of spite but because it's
misinformation these briefings were
substitutes for the rallies there's no
question there it's his outlet its
ability to cam the stage who knows you
nominate the newscast
there's also Trump using this as a
political platform to promote the
messages that he is not able to promote
at rallies because he can't hold rallies
right now here's President Trump
clashing with the media just so you
understand are you ready I think there
are certain people that would like it
not to open so quickly I think there are
certain people that would like it to do
financially poorly because they think
that would be very good as far as
defeating me at the polls I think it's
very clear that there are people in your
profession that write fake news you do
she does we've done one hell of a job
nobody's done the job that we've done
and it's lucky that you have this group
here right now for this problem Dana I'm
going to go to you first we worked at
the White House the insanity of this is
they don't want the American people to
hear from the President of the United
States live in the greatest crisis of
our lives that's how nuts this is yeah I
don't really understand how somebody's
political analysis of the president's
briefing is more important than the
president's briefing while he is you
know basically commanding the ship and I
know that a lot of them don't like it
that President Trump is the president
but he is the president and he is the
one that is entrusted in making this
decisions that have to do with our
livelihoods and our health and the thing
that he has done is surround himself
with people at those briefings that also
take questions like they've never seen
anything like this where you could have
a brief in the last two and a half hours
I mean maybe that's part of the
frustration for the media they want to
see their own faces on TV but here's the
thing there's a lot of great places
including here at Fox News where you can
get the full information if your local
station or your local radio or decides
not to cover it you got a place to go
Greg just talked about the fact that
these individuals would rather hear
themselves speak then and then a
president providing information to all
Americans who carry care about their
health and their loved ones it caught in
competent people fear competition
because the competition exposes their
own idiocy for example this is not a
this argument should sound familiar to
anybody who worked at Fox because you're
successful don't air them that was the
same argument when Fox News came up
because if you can't beat them get rid
of them and that's the whole thing so
Trump gets on the air we all know that
he he's a ratings winner we saw that
that's how CNN and Morning Joe elected
him they put him on their air all the
time and then he became president and
now they're like how dare he well they
should cover him because he's the he
happens to be the commander in chief
during a pandemic you know with cnn.com
reported on Megan Megan Marco is
forbidding Prince Harry from visiting
his father that's what they're covering
but the pandemic briefing forget that
one you've got a lifelong newsman you
can't be in favor of this well I think
is he's the president and so I always
think you've got to cover what the
president has to say but I he has turned
this into basically a political rally
event it's the truck show so every day
he gets this Trump show platform and he
does deliver a lot of misinformation
he's you know when he's asked how he's
doing he's doing perfectly it's as
perfect as the call to the Ukrainian
president when he's asked about
Governor Cuomo laters hang on a second
hang on hang on hang on a second diggin
diggin he said that I didn't say that he
said it was as perfect as his phone call
to the Ukrainians and he says things
like oh we've caught up totally with the
testing with regard to South Korea when
in fact
South we're far apart South Korea is a
small much smaller country than we are I
think they've tested like one out of
every 150 people we've tested one out of
every nine hundred and we're way behind
so he says all these things people come
to these briefings for real information
and instead they're getting a political
presentation and I think that's why a
lot of people say yes he's the president
you got to make sure the American people
have access to what he's saying but now
the question arises as a journalist are
we supposed to just say oh yeah whatever
he says is fine I only person left on
the earth that takes trump word-for-word
what he's trying to do is present
optimism to bouchy is the good cut he's
the good cop foul she's the bad cop they
both want the same thing but you're
acting like this is 2016 all over again
where when he says something it's
directionally true sometimes he gets a
little some little things wrong but the
American public actually understands it
it's only there inside the beltway
journalists who are always wrong on this
and that's why you're always so far
behind on the real stories because you
sit there and you just know these things
I think the real story is that the
people want leadership they can end up
getting it I think that's why doctor
foul Chi hat they're not getting it from
Trump they get it from foul Chi they get
from dr. Burks they feel but but it's a
bad job no Trump's doing Trump's doing a
bang-up job of putting on a TV show that
gets great there you go
you just can't do it can you Juan you
can't admit a little bit Jesse when you
say DS that you said he's making a
mistake
let go the media worrying about
misinformation is like the Mafia
worrying about crime look in the mirror
see them live for two years we should
take them off the ear here come on this
is what they're worried about President
Trump has turned the media into c-span
that's all they are now they point a
camera and they take live press
conferences and they can't add their
analysts and their pundits and reporters
to spin it slice and dice it and edit it
and put a little special sauce and serve
it to the public they get stuff raw now
and the American people are in the mood
for raw material and they don't want
anymore spin the media thinks that
they're smarter than the president and
they have to point out every little time
that they think they're smarter and they
got them but that's not true because the
American public trusts the president
more than they trust the media they like
him more and it's because he's more
compelling he's more honest and he's
more straightforward and that's the
truth because when he goes up there
you're not only getting a real face to
face reality you're gonna get man that's
pretty entertaining and they can speak
in solid-gold sound bites that every
single American can understand they're
jealous of them they don't have anybody
on those networks that can compete with
that kind of talent they don't have it
in Hollywood they don't have it at CNN
they don't have it anywhere and instead
of realizing the deficiency and trying
to work on improving their performance
they're trying to censor the President
of the United States how insane is that
if you want to fact check them one fact
check them afterwards when you have the
13 little boxes on the screen like we do
right now fact check them all day long
but don't cut them off in the middle of
a press conference yeah Danny go ahead I
think he's the one that's trying to take
our time yes you say we're jealous at
him he's I think he's trying to impose
himself on the news curse is the
American people's time
there is no filter litical leader if you
have a political leader who is just like
spouting at the american people you know
at one point you got a war as that
propagates acting great
questions and we're getting great
answers and some of the questions are so
good the task force is going back and
say huh I hadn't thought about it that
way
and then delivering more news about that
same question the next day it's helping
the American people okay well this is
what I was gonna say is that when the
president tweeted around five o'clock
that he was going to be around five ten
and they're gonna focus on this question
of what are these guidelines going to be
that will tell people state governments
local governments companies workers you
can bet people want to tune into that
because they're going to talk about what
are the guidelines going to be how are
we going to get people back to work how
are we going to do this responsibly and
with sensitivity and maybe with some
technology it's possible that we are
going to be able to have this finger
prick test soon that would tell people
you've had it maybe you're immune now
now you can go back to work there's also
going to be the possibility of doing
like in South Korea where you would get
your temperature taken before you were
allowed into the workplace or into a
shop if you were wanting to buy
groceries like they're going to provide
information that is actually really
vital so I can't imagine people not
wanting to take this press conference
this one in particular coming up because
this is the beginning of the president
laying out how we're going to get back
to work in a responsible way these are
people who want to shut the president
down who lied about Russia collusion for
literally years and now they're playing
doctor on television that's what they're
doing they again they they learn their
medical knowledge from Flesch that's how
smart they are like to learn out of
flesh watch that's a throwback yeah the
sequel was better president President
President Trump in the coronavirus Task
Force briefing is going to start any
moment now so stay with us but in the
meantime hospitals in the outbreaks
epicenter which as you know is New York
City they're being overwhelmed with
kovat 19 patients and cases in the state
now top 37,000 people
once Hass
in the city a single hospital folks is
reporting 13 deaths within 24 hours
doctors are warning of apocalyptic type
conditions and health care workers now
saying they don't have enough protective
gear some nurse is forced to wear trash
bags trash bags to keep themselves safe
and in Boston local news outlets
reporting more than a hundred hospital
workers have in fact contracted the
virus I think what we're seeing now Dana
is this thing is you know spreading into
areas the country that previously
weren't being hit I noticed particularly
in the South New Orleans they're saying
they are having a just a surge of virus
confirmations how do you take that right
well I think that it is showing that
what dr. Fauci and dr. Burks have been
telling us for weeks is coming true like
we know that the social distancing is
having an impact and try to slow the
rate of people that need hospitalization
so that's good one of the reasons to
take the president's briefings is I
believe it was just yesterday or the day
before that the president announced hims
allowing the major disaster declaration
for Louisiana or the emergency
declaration because that allows some
funds and to get there for what they're
going to need and different states are
going to have different problems in
Louisiana one of the problems was big
parties at Mardi Gras okay so we know
that that's a highly dense situation now
take it up there in Wyoming where my
family's from like this is not there at
least yet and it's not overwhelming the
situation yet but that governor also
ordering stay at home now so you see
this phase coming and you can also
hopefully start to see after this
briefing then what does the other side
look like so I think it all is going
according to how with the foul chiyan
Burks have been telling the president
from the beginning it was going to go
and Jesse what do you think about the
hospital workers you know the poor
people having to go to work that they
don't have the proper garb so they're
putting on garbage bags and now there's
the question you know do
the nurses the doctors all of the people
who make things happen at the hospital
keep going to work or do they say hey we
can't handle it oh I hope they don't
stop going to work because that that's
the best we have right now on
Governor Cuomo says that they have
enough equipment right now for the
hospitals I guess maybe there is a
disconnect because you've obviously seen
pictures of people with that type of
garb I spoke to a guy today who's a
doctor at Cornell Medical up in New York
and New York City and he says he's
confident now and here's why he knows
how to not get coronavirus and he's on
the front lines he says one of the
biggest mistakes you can make is
touching your face he says if you do
everything to avoid touching your face
that is the number one way to transmit
something you touch someone you'd shake
their hand you touch a surface and you
haven't been pure Elling or you're in a
small room with someone for 30 to 45
minutes who's infected and then you
touch your face that is the number one
way that this thing gets transmitted so
you got to stop touching your face and
you have to carry Purell around
everywhere and you have to really watch
out what surfaces you're touching but
with that knowledge everybody can social
distance and stay clean and that's how
we're gonna get this thing solved
eventually I just want to say Greg what
do you think of No just quickly I want
to point out one of my friends is
working in an emergency room and they
think he actually got double pneumonia
from coronavirus like several weeks ago
and wasn't diagnosed with it and these
people are putting their lives on the
line to save New Yorkers and they would
gladly do it for every single American
never forget that just I just want to
add before the president comes out a
very important question who are the
patients that are dying were they
previously healthy young patients and
did they receive any of the
hydroxychloroquine plus the antibiotics
because I'm interested in knowing has
anybody died from that drug because I
haven't heard it all I've heard
anecdotally from doctors is that when
you get that drug you get better so you
got to demand that if you have symptoms
you got to talk to your doctor we don't
know anything about the patients that
are succumbing